de la misma manera que trabajamos con
los espejos parabólicos lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es poner objetos a
diferentes distancias de excelente
convexo y pensar en cómo será su imagen
el objetivo de hacer esto no es sólo
saber cómo se comporta la luz en
excelente sino también practicar nuestra
lógica sobre cómo analizar los rayos de
luz
primero pondré un objeto que se
encuentre más lejos que el doble de la
distancia focal vamos a dibujar nuestro
objeto aquí con la convención de que el
objeto lo señalamos con una flecha me
quedo medio checo pero bueno cuando
hablamos de espejos parabólicos
recordamos que lo que teníamos al doble
de la distancia focal lo llamábamos
centro de curvatura pero en este caso de
los lentes simplemente lo vamos a llamar
el doble de distancia focal porque aquí
no tenemos centro de curvatura de
ninguna de ambas curvaturas que tenemos
acá que ha dicho esto veamos cuáles será
la imagen resultante en este ejemplo
cuando la luz se refracta en excelente y
como siempre comenzamos dibujando un
rayo de luz que emana del objeto
y recordamos que todo este cuerpo
refleja la luz y fusión mente así que
nosotros elegimos aquellos rayos de luz
que nos convienen para este análisis
vamos a tomar uno que salga de la punta
del objeto y que sea paralelo al eje
principal de manera que va acá llega al
lente no voy a explicar todas las
refracciones que existen dentro del
lente simplemente basta con decir que lo
que pase por acá va a ir hacia el foco
del otro lado y va a pasar así voy a
tomar un rayo de luz que sale de este
mismo punto pero ahora va a pasar por el
punto focal más o menos
si voy con calma ok y llegando al lente
se va a retractar
de esta manera
si yo hiciera esto para todos los puntos
de luz de este objeto nos quedaría una
imagen real de este lado que se vería
más o menos así más o menos así
aquí esta es una imagen real
imagen
que está invertida
invertida
y además es más pequeña que la imagen
original
pequeña
y también noten nuestro objeto original
se encontraba más lejano que dos
distancias focales y la imagen y la
imagen real está a una distancia más
cercana al espejo hagamos otro ejemplo
voy a copiar esta imagen que ya había
previamente copiado
y ahora en este caso voy a colocar mi
objeto sobre el punto que marca las dos
distancias focales mi objeto va a estar
aquí y de nuevo ya saben vamos a tomar
un rayo que salga paralelo al eje
principal
salem y rayo acá llegué al ente se
refracta y va a pasar por el foco
y ahora tengo otro rayo de luz que sale
de este mismo punto del objeto pasa por
el foco
y se refracta de esta manera
interceptándose en este punto
y como pueden ver este es un
paralelogramo esta distancia de aquí es
la misma que la distancia que se
encuentra aquí y la distancia de este
otro lado es la misma que la distancia
de este lado por lo que nuestra imagen
real va a salir de este punto iba a
llegar acá
en este caso nuestra imagen real bueno
es una imagen real
imagen
en este caso va a ser del mismo tamaño
bueno va a estar invertida pero va a ser
del mismo tamaño que nuestro objeto
original invertida
invertida
del mismo tamaño del mismo tamaño
y van a estar a la misma distancia están
a dos distancias focales
el objeto original y su imagen real
vamos a hacer un ejemplo más aquí
necesito tener más espacio
copio la imagen que ya tenía la colocó
en una posición que no sea conveniente
ahí está ahora el objeto de interés lo
vamos a dibujar entre una distancia
focal y dos distancias focales más o
menos por acá
ahora vamos a cambiarle de color al
objeto y lo ponemos así
y ya se podrán imaginar ustedes qué es
lo que vamos a hacer tomamos nuestros
puntos de luz paralelo al eje principal
y que sale de esta punta del objeto
llega al ente y que hace muy bien se
refracta de forma paralela
tomamos otro rayo que sale de este mismo
punto y va a pasar por nuestro foco
va a llegar al ente se va a retractar de
forma paralela al eje en este otro lado
y nos va a quedar esta intersección me
quedo medio chueco pero bueno es para
que se den una idea qué va a pasar aquí
bueno ahora vamos a seguir teniendo una
imagen real pero la imagen real
resultante además de estar invertida va
a estar aquí va a estar más lejana del
lente que el objeto original y va a ser
más grande de hecho es la situación
inversa a la que vimos por primera vez
aquí este ejercicio donde tenemos un
objeto de cierto tamaño que estaba más
lejano de dos puntos focales y su imagen
era más chica y estaba más cercana aquí
tenemos el caso contrario el objeto
original está más cercano al lente su
imagen real está más alejada y es más
grande
lo escribimos
imagen real
y me dejen real
invertida
más grande
y más lejana más
aquí arriba se me pasó a poner que es a
la misma distancia misma distancia
hagamos otro par de ejemplos vamos a
hacer más espacio acá de hecho yo creo
que voy a hacer tu vida más espacio voy
a copiar
mi figura la colocó en donde me interesa
que esté y ahora el objeto de interés lo
vamos a dibujar justo en el punto focal
aquí y vamos a hacer el mismo
procedimiento que en los casos
anteriores elegimos este punto de acá
donde vamos a seleccionar un rayo de luz
que va a salir paralelo al eje llega el
lente y va a pasar por el foco
y lo que haríamos normalmente es tratar
de encontrar un rayo que salga de aquí y
pase por el punto focal pero en este
caso nuestro objeto está justamente en
este punto por lo que no podemos hacer
esto vamos a seleccionar un punto que
pase por esta parte central del lente
voy a dibujar la de otro color va a
salir de acá va a pasar por el centro
del lente y va a seguir su camino
y aquí tenemos dos rayos que salen del
mismo punto
pero que después de pasar por el lente
no van a converger y tampoco dan la
impresión de que vayan a provenir de un
punto en común por lo que en este caso
no vamos a tener ninguna imagen ni
virtual ni real si alguien aquí
estuviera observando
pues para esta persona vería que estos
dos rayos pues son rayos paralelos y que
no provienen de algún punto en común así
que en este caso no tenemos imagen
ay
ahora nuestro último caso pegamos
nuestra figura la colocamos y vamos a
analizar nuestro último caso en donde
nuestro objeto de interés se va a
colocar más cercano que una distancia
focal aquí va a estar el objeto
ya saben ustedes qué es lo que hay que
hacer tomamos nuestro rayo de luz que
sale de la punta y es paralelo sale este
rayo acá llega el lente se refracta y va
a pasar por el punto focal
aquí tomaríamos o buscaríamos algún rayo
que pasara por el punto focal en su
dirección hacia el lente pero no tenemos
ninguno lo que hacemos es seleccionar
algún rayo de luz que salga de este
mismo punto del objeto pero que dé la
impresión de que salga con la misma
dirección de lo que lo haría si viniera
del punto focal por lo que elegimos un
rayo que vaya por acá va a llegar al
lente y se va a retractar paralelamente
más o menos así
en este caso qué va a pasar no van a
converger de este otro lado por lo que
no se va a formar imagen real pero si
tenemos a una persona que esté
observando desde acá estos rayos de luz
hay que ojo tan extraño
si tenemos una persona observando estos
rayos de luz le va a dar la impresión de
que ambos rayos vienen de un punto en
común si extendemos esta línea hacia
atrás que es lo que va a ser la mente de
esta persona al observar estos rayos de
luz y si yo extiendo este otro rayo
derecho hacia atrás
va a dar la impresión de que se van a
unir en este punto y para esta persona
va a observar una imagen virtual en este
punto que va a ser más grande que el
objeto original lo va a amplificar y en
esencia lo que está pasando es que
estaba viendo una imagen virtual
amplificada espero que este vídeo haya
sido interesante para ustedes